i'm jim daniel nerditsky we're watching
hikara nakamura face off against gary
kasparov the 2017 st louis rapid and
blitz and we have one c4 from hikaru in
english defense
and
gary immediately starting to think will
he play a symmetrical english will he
play e5 yep he goes for a symmetrical
english
and he carol going to g3 preparing to
fianchetto his bishop and gary doing the
same both sides fianchettoing their
bishops and we see hikaru playing e3
this is a pretty typical setup where the
knight goes to e2
and uh let's see if kasparov repeats
that same setup from the black side e6
would be a possible move here but black
has a lot a lot of other options uh
black can play more ambitiously
sometimes knight c6 and knight f6
kasparov the first to take a pretty long
think leans back in his chair
and of course gary not quite as in touch
with modern opening theory although he
demonstrated so many ideas uh even after
retiring from chess in these blitz
tournaments but this is a five minute
game gary's gonna have to make a move
here
still deciding and whoa going for h5
immediate kingside attack and casting a
glance up at hikaru gary wants to move
that pawn up to h4 and try to disrupt
the coordination of white's pieces
contest the king side hikaru has to
decide is he going to ignore that or is
he going to push his h-pawn up in return
can he play you can play h3 he can play
h4
hicaro definitely a little bit puzzled
at gary's choice but h5 does look pretty
reasonable i think they're already out
of mainstream theory and there's ikaro's
choice he goes d4
kasparov now seeming a little bit
surprised at that move
and presumably yep there he goes he goes
h4
uh accomplishing his aim now hikaru
could take the pawn on c5 but that would
be easy to win back no knight c3 getting
the night out
presumably gary's gonna do the same he
can go knight c6 he can go knight f6
different moves are possible
gary doesn't seem too unhappy with his
position you know it's decent a decent
opening
that's you know what to do now various
moves yes um any karu
yeah both sides seeming pretty satisfied
let's see if gary develops a knight or
will he play his pawn up to d6 to
support the c5 pawn yep not knight c6
and now another big choice for hikaru
who can defend the pawn on d4 he can go
knight g to e2 or knight f3 but that
would allow gary's h pawn to move
forward the more natural move here is to
push the d-pawn up to d5 but then hikara
will have to deal with the possibility
of gary capturing the c3 knight with his
g7 bishop
and permanently ruining white's pawn
structure so it's already a pretty
committal decision for hikaru there's
gary uh casting another furtive look up
at nakamura and he goes d5
and yet another big decision here for
gary he can move his knight uh to the
center to e5 or he can capture the
knight on c3 first which it ruins
white's pawn structure but that would
involve
giving away his dark squared bishop so a
lot of committal decisions here to be
made for both sides in the opening and
we can see hikara having already spent
almost a minute gary has spent well over
a minute and he's had a lot of problems
with time pressure in these blitz games
uh so he's gonna have to speed it up
right about now big decision coming up
this is move seven only
and bishop takes c3 gary
giving away that fiance bishop
and now moving his knight out to e5
accelerating his play just a little bit
the c4 pawn is now hanging
hikaru could defend it in a variety of
ways he can defend it with his queen he
can move his bishop back to f1 but that
seems really really passive maybe hikara
will just jettison the pawn entirely
and focus instead on his development so
one way to do that would be just to
develop his knight knight f3
and maybe gary won't even take the pawn
on c4 because kasparov hasn't developed
either of his other minor pieces the
knight on g8 and the bishop on c8 are
currently undeveloped and even though
the center is closed uh that's not
something you want to procrastinate on
for too long hikaru about to make a move
withdrawing his hand you can see him
fidgeting i think that's a knight he's
fidgeting with whatever he's no maybe
that's gary's bishop and
ikaro yep knight f3 so
he offers the pawn on c4 but if gary
takes it that knight on c4 is going to
be tossed around hikaru could push his
epon upward and that might make it even
harder for black to develop his pieces
so my guess is gary's gonna take on f3
and then play d6 to quickly develop his
other minor pieces
gary once again taking his time i think
he's below three minutes now
which is quite a bit concerning this is
only move nine yep knight takes f3
bishop takes f3
and quickly gary
playing d6 opening up his light squared
bishop so
and hikaru going g4 advancing his pawn
not allowing h takes g3
now gary doesn't seem too happy with
this turn of events now it's a little
bit hard to develop gary's knight like
if gary plays knight f6 he might run
into g5 and that knight will be pushed
around even further
so it might be worth delaying the
development of the knight h3 freezing
white's pawn on g4 not allowing hikaru
to push his h-pawn up himself
interesting choice but very committal
that pawn on h3 might become a very
serious weakness later on in the game
car going g5 and he in turn freezes
black's knight on g8 now that knight
can't develop
at all
unless gary pushes his e pawn up
wow and he doesn't seem too happy
there's that patented head shake i think
black is a little bit worse
and queen a5 hitting the pawn on c3 gary
wasting no time icaru really only has
one liability in the position those are
his queen side pawns on c3 and c4 they
are weak and they're pretty easy to
attack but they're also pretty easy to
defend i think he's yeah just plays
bishop d2 he defends the pawn on c3
and gary needs to find ways to continue
to put pressure on white's queen side
because he can't develop his knight
hikaru definitely wants to go pawn e4
keep expanding in the center
leaning back is gary now leaning back
forward again
continuing to shake his head doesn't
look like gary is too happy with his
position now the position is pretty
closed so i don't think black needs to
be concerned too much and rook up to h4
attacking c4 laterally that's a really
cool move but it can be rebuffed by e4
and there goes he car with e4
stopping the threat of rook takes c4
intercepting the rook but that pawn on
e4 might be a liability gary going e5
which we've kind of expected he opens up
the e7 square for his knight uh which
will at least allow him to complete his
development
now let's see how hikaru tries to
accumulate the pressure
karo a little bit puzzled but e5 seemed
very logical to me goes rook g1
maybe he wants to bring his rook up to
g3 and put pressure on the h3 pawn no
first he goes queen b3
uh slowing down the development of
black's bishop on c8 now b7 is gonna
hang so gary could consider bringing his
own queen back to a6 or c7 in order to
make it possible to develop his bishop
alternatively he could play b6 here
uh and try to fianchetto the bishop or
bring it bring it to a6
and he was hesitating there i think he's
about to move his queen queen c7 queen
a6
both seem possibly ghost queen c7
okay
and now the position is really really
close the center is closed and neither
side can really open it so actually i
think black is doing quite fun maybe
he's a little bit worse because black is
quite cramped bishop d7 gary finally
completes his development and with his
last move bishop e2 i think hikaru is
actually preparing the march of his
f-pawn i think hikara wants to play rook
f1 and then f4 and blast open the f-file
so we'll see what icarucar does here
rook f1
seems really really interesting work f1
followed by f4
and black can still castle queen side no
he car goes a4 a5 so the set the queen
side freezing even further and f3 a
little bit surprising hikaru doesn't uh
doesn't try to accomplish f4 in one fell
swoop kasparov bringing his knight to b6
and king f2 is seekaro bringing his king
to g3
maybe to kick the rook away maybe he
wants to prepare f4 that way
that's a really interesting idea
but i'm not sure
not sure if it's going to work out cause
sparrow can actually castle here
gary has not moved his king so he can
castle queen set and he does castle's
queen side where he's significantly
safer queen b3 by hicaro
king b8 okay that knight on b6 is now
potentially going to be pressured by a
rook rook up to g3 we talked about that
move earlier they're significantly
accelerating the speed of their play
will kasparov bring his rook back from
h4 that rook isn't doing all that much
he's grabbing his other rook and he
brings it to h8 making sure that the h3
pawn
remains safe hikaru drops his king back
to g1 i still think that he wants to
prepare f4 but here's the problem with
white's position if you look at that
pawn on a4
that pawn is extremely weak and white
can't really move neither his rook nor
his queen
away from their position so they're tied
down to that pawn king h1 hikaru
continues to by this time bishop v8 the
position really really close so this
game might end in a draw just because
neither player seems to be making any
progress but something tells me hikaru
is not going to be satisfied with that
he's going to try something rook you won
gary a little bit nervous we can look at
that clock i think he's below two
minutes he brings his bishop back to d7
so far both sides feeling each other out
the big question is will hikaru prepare
f4 he goes rook 81 he sacrifices the
pawn on a4 gary doesn't capture it
afraid to open the afl rook b2 knight d7
hikar was threatening to triple on the
b-file and he does but gary just in time
to play b6 okay hikaru brings his rook
back to g1 though he has induced the
move b6 but that pawn is perfectly well
defended by black's pieces queen d8 rook
b1 i think icaru is now going to bring
his other rook to f1 in order to prepare
the f4 pawn push that pawn push has been
on the cards for right about 20 move
down to rook f4 what a move by gary he
brings his rook to f4 well that's a way
to stop f4 sacrificing the exchange but
that's actually a pretty typical
sacrifice because if hikaru takes it
then gary's gonna take back with the
pawn and put a knight on e5 that knight
is going to be a monster and hikara will
have no way to make progress this was an
amazing move by gary
f6 wow he doesn't bring the now he
sacrifices the other rook on h4
what an incredible move i think he could
have just brought the rook back to h5
this is a sacrifice i think hikaru is
going to accept he does maybe gary can
fuse something he's down to 20 seconds
he car takes on f6 and now the position
opens up just a little bit gary
recaptures with the queen i still think
black is pretty decent compensation
though queen d2
maybe queen f4 or rook f4 yep he goes
queen f4
and uh
let's see if hikaru trade queens now if
you have a queen trade then gary could
potentially get his knight up to e5
and once he does that it seems like
black will have phenomenal compensation
for the exchange
the car does trade gary takes back with
the pawn
and
rook b2 king b7 gear uh icaru doubles
gary gets his king out of the b file at
a dodge
hikaru getting his own king into the
game king g1 king f2 the question though
as gary moves his rook back is how is
hikaru going to make progress and i
think hikara wants to play bishop f1 and
attack the pawn on h3 that pawn is still
a very significant weakness and look at
gary's clock he's down a right about 15
seconds defends the pawn of the rook
rook h5
but how is he car going to get his rooks
into the game that pawn on b6 is
perfectly well protected but the
knight's not going to e5 just yet
but if hikaru can't put more pressure on
h3 i don't see how he's gonna make
progress gary
his hands are shaking he goes rook h4
so far just binding his time maybe he
car can push that e pawn down the board
sacrifice it but open up the position
now instead he brings his king further
toward the center gary moving his rook
back and forth he's basically saying all
righty caro
you i don't know how you're going to
make progress here a lot of moves fast
bishop e2 gary continues to move his
rook between h5 and h4 icarus rook to g1
gary finally puts his 995
okay bishop out to d7 looks like gary
keeps making progress now the pawn on h3
can be defended by the bishop as well
and hikaru's resources seem to be
exhausted here you can see the
frustration as he continues to maneuver
gets his king again to d2 but gary just
going back and forth with his bishop
he's telling carl where are you going
with your king being d8 he carves
cutting the king all the way to b3
back to b2 back to b3 looks like he
carves frustrated doesn't seem to be
making any progress at all gary moving
his king back between c7 and d8 and rook
g4
okay
cavern sacrificing the exchange he's
going to take that f4 pawn but look at
fury's knight on e5 i don't think gary's
gonna lose the game with that knight on
e5
he's still got plenty of time on the
clock the position simplifying we have a
rook trade
and i think gary's just got a fortress
he can even sacrifice the pawn on h3
even if he sacrifices it i still think
he's going to be fine power getting his
king to the center gary doing the same
thing for a lot of moves being played
and gary getting his knight to e5 he has
sacrificed the pawn on each three cara
can just take that pawn now but gary's
going to put his pawn on g5 and i think
he's going to put his knight on e5 and i
think he's going to have a fortress and
i think he car realizes it we're going
to have 95 here
ricardo defending the pawn on c4 knight
back to g6 stopping h4 and if he car
doesn't play h4 then that's it we have a
draw by agreement what an incredible
game what a tense game and if you want
to see more videos like this click on
the playlist that's popping up on your
screen right now i'm jim daniel nerdisky
hope you enjoyed this game
[Music]
you